joining us back here on the Rich Eisen
show from NBC sports Boston his column
of posted last Wednesday was entitled
are these Tom Brady's final days with
the Patriots question mark it was a
rhetorical question the answer to which
will be provided right now by Tom Curren
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Tom I'm not telling I'm not telling
don't poke me up don't don't you sell me
down the river that way rich I mean it's
it I read your cuz I read your your
stuff Tom you said it sure sounds like
it is why Patriots say it needs a
radical horse change to avert what
appears to be a divorce and it could
still be an amicable divorce it could be
just simply irreconcilable differences
we go each other's ways or it could get
ugly but it does certainly seem that way
unless there's a radical course change
well I mean I assume losing to the
Kansas City Chiefs at home is not the
radical course change that we're looking
for what is an amicable divorce look
like Tom where they just say we're both
done here I mean yeah they say look Tom
you want 27 million dollars which is
highly reasonable since Jimmy Garoppolo
for instance makes 27 this year we paid
you 23 in 2019 we paid you you know
fifteen or sixteen with incentives that
weren't even able to come close to hit
2018 you want to get paid more which
it's not gonna do it I'm gonna think
that kind of money into it compared to
says yeah I understand I felt that might
be coming forty-three things bugging
isn't it well I'm gonna go someplace
else or at least see what else is out
there and once he finds that rich and
it's the right situation which I think
he could find he'll go to it I really
don't think retirement is anywhere in
his sights and again I'm speaking of my
perspective no one's telling me how it's
going to play out I'm just watching the
way things are adding up you know
they're not making predictions that this
is what's going to happen but the
radical course change that's informed
opinion well then let's let's continue
pulling on this thread what what is the
the right scenario for him I mean give
me when he goes shopping and some team
raises their hand what is the right
scenario for him that is actually
feasible what
come March and if I can just take the
liberty I think probably people sitting
out there and saying how did it get to
this and I think it got to this
beginning in 2014 before I get to the
scenario you know when you are the
Patriots you try and have a succession
plan you put in place with Jimmy
Garoppolo you draft him in 2014 a year
after the sign Brady to a contract that
brought him through 2017 his 40 year old
season and Robert Kraft said at the time
you know what this was an quote unquote
elegant way of doing things I did it as
a fan I don't want him to ever be
anyplace else they've done all they can
and more in their minds in their minds
to make sure that he retires the Patriot
if he wants to keep playing for a
certain amount of money in a certain
amount of the salary cap 43 and the
Patriots want to start to reboot move on
then that's why the split would happen
amicable not amicable
I would hope it would be the former just
for the way things have gone but that
often is difficult to have happen what
would be ideal honestly rich knowing who
he is since he's been in the public
consciousness for twenty years and more
he wants to be able to prove something
to somebody who thought that he couldn't
do something that he was unable to
continue at a level and that's why I
keep coming back to the Miami Dolphins
as a possibility scripture Michigan man
friend Steven Ross and charge
it's got Jerry Scheff Winsky as a
quarterbacks coach and shadow shares
your offensive coordinator and Brian
Flores as the head coach got defensive
personnel on the other side it certainly
got a culture I think that's being
instilled this year so there well Los
Angeles would be the two prime places
but again I don't think they're even
debating at this juncture where he might
land I know the charges would be all
over that and they're all due respect to
Philip Rivers I mean if you want to
shake things up to what you know to try
and get people to buy tickets in a new
building come see Tom Brady play even
though he's 43 and at least that that
might be a team that is close to a Super
Bowl but wouldn't be able to sit there
in the AFC's to play twice in New
England so let's just that's Tom Curren
here on the Rich Eisen show and in terms
of you know turning things completely
around
and have a radical course change that
would mean making a deep run into the
playoffs right now Tom and this is the
midway point of our conversation so it's
time for everybody to start booing us I
think Tom based on a saw yesterday what
do you make of the boos in July
yesterday I don't mind boos I really
don't like it it's it's a review not of
the 20 years which I think a lot of
people have a you can't boo because they
did something back last February you I
you're saying I loudly and verbally
reject what I've been watching and
that's okay with me
yeah it's a little bit narrow it's a
little bit short-sighted there will be a
time when a half like that that the
Patriots put out there people are gonna
be saying you know that wasn't that bad
it's probably not that long in the
future either so but people aren't used
to having a book like that nor are they
used to having them kind of just tuck
tail and go into the locker room which
they did with timeouts still in their
pocket so the booing doesn't bother me
but people are having a very difficult
time aside from what they saw in the
first half wrapping their head around
the fact that they're not going to be
able to wave a magic wand like they did
in 2018 and have everything go fine
because they're not looking at details
of 2018 closely enough and I don't
babble on no no that's the reason why I
frame the booing long terms of the way
that I did which is I think it is
indicative of a certain fear in the fan
base that this is finally different that
this looks different that said the
Nikhil Harry touchdown that wasn't
because they botched his foot actually
being inbounds rather than out of bounds
as they called it to me looked like a
physical athletic play on the outside
that's missing that might suddenly start
sparking and then there's the question
that I have for you on on the run game
how in the world does Sony Michele go
from setting a record for most
touchdowns by a rookie in a post season
last year and how
the world does Josh Jacobs who's the
Offensive Rookie of the Year in Oakland
and Naja Harris who's been dynamite for
Alabama this year none of them can
leapfrog Damien Harris on the depth
chart in Alabama and he's drafted by the
Patriots and he's a healthy scratch
every week what's with the run game in
New England Tom it's almost as if the
offensive line and the guys who open the
holes matter mm-hmm
not to be a smartass but yeah that's
that's what it comes down to I mean
David Andrews isn't just injured it's
David Andrews his backup Ted Karras and
then James Ferris was in there yesterday
Trent Brown was an outstanding left
tackle last year he was moved out
because Isaiah Wynn was present and then
he was hurt so Marshall Newhouse was
barely NFL level was in their cannon and
Mason on the right side haven't been
good and the biggest part of it is you
took not only Rob Gronkowski one of the
all-time greatest blocking tight ends
who was absolutely critical in the
team's ability to run the ball last year
but you took Dwayne Allen out of the mix
and he didn't replace him so that's just
a fleet of differences that Dante scar
Nikia can't overcome and then we get to
the stuff with Nikhil Harry and Bill
Belichick talked about it on the
conference call today you only play two
snaps go to rich you played two snaps
one of them was the near touchdown of
course he's imeem I hate to say it he's
only 21 22 years old but he got hurt he
had a hip injury by the end of that play
he missed months in the preseason
because he caught two cab passes a pre
shaken game and missed the next three
months but yeah he's got that physical
attribute but bill said look he's just
got a long long way to go so something
that we're not something that is we're
seeing the tip of the iceberg and that
12-yard play that got him to the brink
of the end zone should have been
touchdown but the iceberg underneath has
much more I'm guessing it leads him to
believe that he's not what they want on
the field well and then part of the
iceberg also you can take a look at
Seattle DK Metcalf was on the board they
took knee tell Harry instead and we look
up what he's doing right now
he's decaf Metcalfe is percolating if
you will in Seattle and then on top of
all of that to Josh Gordon was making
some plays last night do we know what
happened there in New England where why
he can't because he's in it he would
have been enhancer here obviously for
the Patriot Jacob Hollister I mean he's
cruised around out there and made plays
as well with Josh Gordon the rumblings
were that he was becoming less
dependable and his he wasn't on the
details of the way they had hoped and in
terms of being where it was supposed to
be what he was supposed to be there
wasn't necessarily missing meetings but
wasn't necessarily exactly where they
hoped he would be and you know when you
look at his situation he was dropped in
their lap in August at the end of August
and I thought it was interesting to hear
Bill Belichick's comments when he was
reinstated even though they stuck with
him he wasn't over the moon it was like
a yeah well we'll see how it goes with
him when I activate him right away we'll
see how it goes let's see we've got we
haven't seen him in six months so I
think he was on a very very very short
leash and it's his recovery from the
injury that he had continued and went a
little longer than I thought it would
and they other things cropped up I think
they said better to get out early on
this then later well look Tom I'm
obviously invested in this for many
reasons my family's a bunch of Patriots
fans I'm a big I'm a big look I'm a big
Tom Brady guy on top of it Bill
Belichick said working on the NFL 100
all-time team show made him a better
coach so if he doesn't make the playoff
run here after that maybe people start
looking at me and I can't have it so how
do you think this all winds up from here
Tom best guess for me rich they got a
school more than 20 points all the time
they have to score more than 20 points
offensive weight because you can't
expect a defense going against playoff
caliber teams to keep everybody under 20
points yesterday the excusing healthy
player standing next scored on a short
field yesterday last week right uh
yesterday the opponent to you what is
the hell I'm too tired no brother he was
yesterday scored on a short field
yesterday as well - yeah I know
okay Texans Ravens jeez
know any interesting thing is the four
division leaders the Patriots three
losses are to the three other division
leaders you know they're punching in
short field touchdown so it's not even
like they're allowing 28 or 21 points to
allowing 20 but the Patriots have no
shot of scoring more than 20 so this
defense has to do an incredible amount
for the Patriots to advance to where
people think they are but this year
unlike last year there is no healthy
player who's going to come back and make
a difference as Kronstadt down the
stretch there are health issues there
are personnel issues there are
continuity issues so it's it's a tough
road to hoe Tom appreciate the time man
appreciate the time I'm doing I'm doing
your pod tomorrow right at the moment
home Patriots talk yep I went I went
Patriots talk podcast on currents
Patriots talk podcast and I want full
details on that NFL 100 think on and I
have enjoyed the hell out of it well I
mean again this past week episode on
Friday where Edie Reed showed up and and
my favorite part about it is that the
Bella straighter that bill uses that a
lot of fans know from him with Zola
Krait locally in in New England where he
just shows off his X's and O's and and
his passion for the game we have only
him does he does that only for old
school you know grainy film players for
some for some of the show this time
though he told Edie read during the
commercial break where and he just threw
this on everybody he goes hey Edie
I'd like to show some of your film on on
the film segment and then so you know
it's not like there was a scrambling or
anything like that but all the producers
got around of course we're gonna do what
Bill was wanted to do and Ed reads like
absolutely and I said to Adam like ed he
has not asked this of any other players
that have been here and there have been
some all-time greats here he loves and
read I mean absolutely loves ed and I
just loved that he everybody got to see
that passion in a way and it's funny
because Bill used to you don't Brady's
to we'd ask him about Ed Reid he goes oh
you mean that Belichick is that right
yeah yeah you'd call him Oh ed Belichick
yeah it's like those kid
and you don't last thing I'll say before
you have to get me the hell out of here
is I'm such a football addict I mean I
grew up reading Super Bowl books I don't
know why we had them in our library at
hob Mach elementary school but I know
those players and I to hear Belichick
mentioned John Jefferson the other day
and talking about my canes John
Jefferson was my guy he was everybody's
guy he might have been your guy to know
sure back in the early eighties oh yeah
man I just every week it's great and
there's three more episodes to go and
the I believe the quarterback show that
finishes up has now been expanded to two
hours I mean it's all going to be great
for the rest of this month thanks for
the time Tom I can't wait for the tight
ends I think it's gonna be fascinating
for folks around here I don't know
what's going to happen I don't but I
hope it's really a fascinating show for
folks around here it will be tight ends
and an offensive lineman coming up on
Friday and then I'll be on your pod
tomorrow Tom thanks to the time here at
Tommy caron on twitter for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on be our live
or download the Rich Eisen show app